hello tardy box Tim bunk
sorry you are merciful giant tiny box is
not exactly what I would call tiny
anymore but still very nice don't kill
the kiddies good job well alright then
the jump scare of soccer balls
who would have known Oh what's a kitty
run oh oh no no no no no no no no you
made vanish in happy wheels what kind of
I can't see a damn thing you revived
glows thanks again cast B 405 for
playing this you guys should check out
casts peas levels
they're awesome Marga Blaire spike fall
this is the biggest spike fault why is
it raining blood should I even ask I'll
just go on my way then weep
oh well here we go there go don't go
horizontal oh I was close
Oh pull back on the reins I'm the
official maker of myths and things okay
oh that did not Oh
troll level oh I thought it was gonna be
something like that but okay your trolls
are different than I thought they were
god I see exactly this is gonna be okay
no no no no no no no I gotta get this
oh my poor son oh I believe the danger
okay Oh probably the danger would have
still been danger what is that what am I
even looking okay well then all right
never mind job why oh god oh god oh I
don't like a lot of things that are
going on in this level still don't trust
it what's this
what whoa mr. jet from his crotch
okay this is all very lovely oh no it's
a horrible felt the rainbow on that last
one back sans gonna do a double tuck on
the rock balls could just get a little
bit of a break [ __ ] anybody now I'm
gonna wait for the next pass and drop a
button but it's going spike Falls a
little hurt on this okay okay all right
okay this is gonna end horribly oh maybe
we cannot suck and I we go going
horizontal ball
I counts what the secret Brahma o
harpoon oh I got it brought you love
goodbye
stress again that she'll whoa okay
caught it with my faith hi babe into the
desk oh I missed it well pub that
doesn't I must kill him Who am I must
kill I know when these are just hard to
throw all right then no I don't want to
oh god sure fooled you good enough yeah
good enough I got two for you part one
whoa sorry mr. Goomba I did not know
that's somewhat horrifying this turned
into goop thank you yeah I know I know I
know I know I know
you just made that literally impossible
in markiplier 99% impossible well that's
probably why it's going to be impossible
my skill level is incredible now oh boy
I'm
okay all right all right okay damn that
was a well design hard one because it
wasn't just plain old lock Oh
also remember there's a ton of new
markiplier levels coming out on the
happy wheels browser you can check him
out at any time
search for Marga bar vote up the ones
you like because there's a lot of really
talented stuff out here so thank you
again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video